I was 15 feet from this guy.
But I was safely in in a Land Rover.
If I had not been I would have been a little stressed out.
My adrenal cortex would have been squirting out cortisol the stress hormone
as I saw this guy. This is an adaptive response.
We undergo some sort of acute stressor.
Our adrenal glands go into action: they squirt cortisol.
We get in a physiological state that prepares us for the sorts of things
that we're likely to have to do to adapt to the stressor.
One of the truly remarkable things about reading a story
(when you're engaged with a story)
you get a major activation of your HPA access,
your Hypothalamus Pituitary Adrenal axis.
This is the classic stress response.
It's the system that regulates stress, but
it's also essential in the control of
the immune system, mood, sexuality and energy.
And I think that this is the foundation
the physiological foundation of that feeling
when you're engaged in a story
and you're really nervous.
I mean reading "Flight Behavior," I'm just so anxious about what's gonna happen to Dellarobia.
What new humiliation of being poor in America
is she gonna have to endure?
And it's that feeling of needing to turn the page.
This is this activation of the HPA axis.
It's cool. Is it useful instrumentally?
And I have to give props to my
Stanford colleague, Robert Sapolsky.
Many of you are probably familiar.
He's an incredible public speaker.
And just a huge intellect.
He has been a good mentor to me.
Why do we care about cortisol,
other than it's kind of cool
that you get this physiological response
to reading a story?
It turns out that stress opens people's minds
to behavior change.
The right kind of stress opens people's minds
University College London psychologist / neuroscientist Tali Sharot
has a fairly recent book on changing people's minds ("The Influential Mind").
And she's quite famous for her technical work
on what's called a positivity bias.
You're faced with information
that comes at you from the world,
you have priors, prior beliefs,
about what the world is like
And when you get information that's good news,
relative to your desires,
you take that and you say
'Good, my hypothesis is supported!'
And when you get bad news, you kind of
ignore it. You don't pay as much attention to it.
Which seems a little paradoxical
It seems like for a survival algorithm
you'd want to learn more from bad news.
That's the way I think about these things.
But it turns out that isn't the way
a lot of people go about doing it.
Until you put them under stress.
When you put people under stress when you give them...
one of these psychologists' funny things that you do:
you tell them they're going to have to give
a public lecture after they do your test
or something like that.
It turns out you open people's minds
to both good news and bad news.
And they behave like proper Bayesians.
They update their priors in a rational kind of way.
Isn't that cool? And that means
they've had their HPA axis activated.
It means they're got that cortisol response.
And that's exactly what good fiction does to you.
Is it possible that there's a physiological foundation for good fiction changing people's valence bias?
Their willingness to accept good and bad news?
It's a hypothesis.